honestly I think it's abusive and that's
why I'm exposing it trans role father is
willing to go to jail
Target now
see so when they're going after like
Muslim youth they're trying to tell them
don't worry you can still be a Muslim
and be a different gender okay I
remember a very nice young hmm come to
think of it well is Alex a boy or a girl
actually Alex doesn't Define themselves
as boy or girl my next guest is a school
teacher with over 25 years experience
also has a psychology degree and she's
going to be exposing us to what our
children are being exposed to in the
educational system this is very
important for everyone to tune in to get
exposed to these facts some very scary
facts that are out there and we'll be
right back with our next guest Brenda
here on the dean show
true
so I'll make home greetings of Peace
welcome to the dean show and we got
another exciting episode we got a lot of
information to share with you very
important information and we're
fortunate enough to have Brenda lebsack
with us you're a school teacher of 20
plus years is that correct correct and
tell us a little bit more about yourself
you also have a you're also from a
psychology background
I did graduate with my Bachelor of
Science in for counseling and then I
went on and went and got my master's
degree in education and then I went into
special education and then later I
taught English in high school and then I
ended up going into PE and now I'm
teaching kids with disabilities PE
and so you you've been uh in the field
of education for quite some time very
long time over 20 years
yes 25 years 25 years
School Board I was
I was on a school board
um for four years now a good friend of
mine uh Imam Shea uh Omar Mustafa uh he
shared a an event that you guys had at
his local mosque where you were speaking
and you were actually informing uh the
community there how they were
specifically targeting Muslim youth
and this was very alarming can you share
some of that with us that you were
sharing with uh them there at the mosque
in California
um yes a 4
a 14 a curriculum for sex education
um I was really surprised in some of the
things I found the content and coming
from the California Department of
Education
um they were recommended to teachers and
to students a particular website called
advocates for Youth and when I went to
that website before having to vote on it
as a board member to approve this
curriculum I noticed in their articles
that were targeting specifically Muslim
Youth and they were it had an article in
it
um specifically that said I'm Muslim but
I'm a different gender or I think I'm a
different gender and then it would
quote the Quran and the prophets and I
was you know I'm a person of Faith
myself I'm not a Muslim but I know that
when you take a sacred writing and you
start interpreting it incorrectly I was
just really bothered by that and
Disturbed and so I took that information
to um my local mosque in Orange County
to an Imam yeah was that was that the uh
friend of mine that uh shared that with
me was that him specifically or somebody
else it was actually someone else I met
a few other imams Dr Siddiqui and also
Dr
um Ahmed Sabo before I met um Imam
Mustafa Mustafa yes tell me so when I
said they are targeting Muslim Youth and
just children in general but
specifically you saw here with how they
were changing the text of the Quran or
they were manipulating things but who is
they
that's a good question
um they would be
the
advocates for youth I all I know is
who's endorsing advocates for youth I
don't actually know who writes the
website but it's being endorsed by the
California Department of Education
um advocates for youth also helped write
our sex ed standards
um our learning professional sex ed
standards along with Planned Parenthood
and another agency
um called healthy teen Network there's a
video here that I want the audience to
see and then we can take off because
some of these things it's just hard to
wrap your mind around it because for
since the beginning it's always been
where God Almighty created man and woman
male and female has kind of been
straightforward but from listening to
your talk and you explaining these
things now you got her sir Z he she tree
people are talking about if they want to
be a tree is that true they can be a
tree you can call them a tree
uh what we're talking about is unlimited
genders so unlimited genders
correct when you have it's called a
range of genders and what I noticed is I
noticed it in the curriculum curriculum
for young children
um we have a couple different agencies
that put out this curriculum one is also
called
um the Human Rights Campaign and they
have a lot of curriculum that's called
welcoming schools and all of these words
sound wonderful inclusion compassion
empathy
um you know tolerance they all sound
great you know respect safe we all want
those things but then when you look
inside a little deeper and see some of
these books for preschool kindergarten
first grade
um that they're teaching these kids that
they can be you know different genders
based on their feelings and whatever
they choose not just transgender it goes
beyond that it's called the gender
spectrum and the first time I learned
about it was actually in 2017
um there's an article that came out
because I'm a teacher I'm part of the
teachers union and in March 2017 it came
out in our teachers magazine mailed to
my house called the gender spectrum and
when I saw this they said you can be
gender fluid
um you can be you know all these
different genders it wasn't you can be
both genders neither gender anything in
between and then they had all these
different pronouns and they said
transgender is just one of the many
different genders a child can choose
and that's when I started I I never
heard that before until 2017 from my
teachers union magazine now this next
video we're going to share this is
actually one of the videos that goes out
to the Educators to the teachers is that
correct and then they form a
curriculum off off of this or there's a
curriculum that goes with this that
pushes this
um how does that work
place.org video yes it's it's called a
range of genders yes that one is
in a lot of different ways it's promoted
through the Southern Poverty Law Center
um they put out a magazine to teachers
called teaching tolerance and if you see
right here I mean I can give you a
closer visual but it's showing um this
is a free resource in advocates for
youth for teachers because it has all
these free videos and this is the way we
need to teach tolerance in our classroom
is the mini it's coming under the
umbrella of diversity teaching these
unlimited genders I also found it right
here
um in this magazine is actually put out
by the Association of California school
administrators so the this is a magazine
that is received by principals
superintendents anybody who's in any
type of leadership of disc school
districts or schools and I found an
article in here that also
um it's called a an lgbtq plus inclusive
culture begins in elementary school and
again it's recommending um these books
of unlimited genders
so I'll go ahead maze.org video is um
it's recommended by these groups it's
also recommended through advocates for
youth in for the California Department
of Education and Advocates are for youth
is not just
um California it's a national website
all right folks here we go a romaine and
kale salad with avocado cucumber
shishito peppers and four kinds of
cheese sprinkled in balsamic Straight
From Italy wow in My Day salads only had
two ingredients a rock hard wedge of
iceberg lettuce and a stinky old dried
up tomato
sorry guys I'm gonna have to eat fast
Alex is stopping by in a few minutes to
work on our robotics project Alex is
that the girl with that weird dog or the
boy with the hat with the wings that
flap no Uncle Jay this is Alex oh okay I
remember a very nice young hmm come to
think of it well is Alex a boy or a girl
actually Alex doesn't Define themselves
as boy or girl what else is there back
in your day most people understood the
world in terms of just boys and girls
but now we know gender is more complex
than that wait aren't we just talking
about whether you're born with
aura when you're born your sex is
assigned in a medical way but the sex
listed on your birth certificate may not
necessarily match your gender identity
gender identity is a person's inner
experience of who they are in terms of
gender their deep personal sense of
being male female a blender both or
neither and while many people have a
gender identity that's the same as their
assigned birth sex of female or male
that's not always the case because
gender exists on a spectrum like
transgender which means a person whose
gender identity is not consistent with
their assigned birth sex
non-binary which means a person whose
identity doesn't fall in the category of
either male or female and genderqueer or
gender fluid which means a person who
does not identify themselves as having a
specific gender at all
does gender identity have to do with
being straight or gay actually no gender
identity has to do with the way you feel
about yourself while sexual orientation
is based on the way you feel toward
others the people you may or may not be
attracted to you know I really like Alex
and I can tell they're a good friend to
you but I'm still pretty confused about
all of this that's okay you don't have
to fully understand someone to respect
them to start try not to make any
assumptions about a person's gender and
use the name and pronouns that they ask
you to
above all be a friend or Ally for people
of all gender identities I guess the uh
storyline starts off with someone who
they consider back in your day someone
who owns old school so now this is the
new school
correct yeah so in the old school it was
kind of straightforward it wasn't as
confusing but now it's something that's
a little bit more complex can you go
more into this
what what what's uh the psychology
behind this and what what what should we
I mean uh your thoughts
yeah the word that comes up over and
over is the word evolve that our genders
are evolving
um I'm seeing that in a lot of documents
and that we need it's Progressive and
I'm not sure how they say this is based
on science it makes no common sense to
me
um but they're saying based on science
is children choosing
um whatever gender they want to be
based on their feelings and that to them
is what's called science and progress
okay let's let's let's stop there you
said science I mean is there any science
to back any of this up
it's actually in the CDC
um the CDC backs up unlimited genders as
of December 2019.
um they are using a lot of new words
that people don't know and what the word
is non-binary see binary means to male
and female by two the prefix by but when
you have non-binary that means it's
outside of male and female it's
somewhere on the Spectrum and they
Define that as being both neither or
something else which could be unlimited
um based on really your imagination it
seems like I mean how that you you gave
a good analogy or you gave us true story
about your friends they're actually
um were they in law enforcement and
there are scientists for the line for
what what field were they in and then
you consulted with them uh oh I was
talking to a forensic scientist and I
asked them during their investigations
when they were trying to find a suspect
did they ever run into a non-binary
person based on blood samples and they
said no we've never run into that in all
of our years and these were very very
experienced forensic scientists
and I said well that's interesting
because they're saying that non-binary
is based on science
but honestly when I went because I
wanted to find out the origin as far as
in the state of California where this
came from and I went I found it the
definition in the state of California
changed in July of 2017.
um this should have been national news
but it was nowhere to be heard it
actually changed in the fair housing
Fair Employment hearing so I contacted
them and asked for the 300 Page hearing
so I could read it and when I read it I
found out it came from the transgender
Law Center and equality California those
were the two groups lobbying for the
change definition and the fair housing
Fair Employment went right along with it
but it seems like there's more a push
through this to actually have children
who are already at a stage you know when
you're going through life as a child
you're growing up you're already
confused about things just life in
general and a lot of times you know you
go through the natural process and you
just grow out of things but would you
say that this actually just gets
children even more confused and then it
just ends up complicating their lives
even more and it's it seems like this is
an ideology that's pushing the children
away from their natural way
oh I 100 agree honestly I think it's
abusive and that's why I'm exposing it
and I can show you some of the the books
and I can say for myself because I was a
tomboy growing up
um I liked all the boy things I didn't
play with dolls I played Pirates and
cops and robbers and if I would have
been taught these things as a young
child I would have definitely thought I
was a boy it's very very confusing and
the fact is what the stats show is any
kids that do have any of that gender
dysphoria or confusion
um typically grow out of it after
puberty like 90 grow out of it and so to
put these thoughts into a young child's
mind who is innately imaginative
innately trusting and
um impressionable is to me exploitation
it's wrong
I mean that's and you know it from a
psychology background having a degree in
that
what is that doing I mean it seems like
it's systematically set up targeting
children at this specific young age
well absolutely because the laws at
least in California are saying that once
a child starts
um identifying as a different gender or
even starts questioning their gender
because lgbtq the Q in lgbtq means queer
or questioning so once they even start
questioning they're put into that
category of lgbtq
and the social workers and the health
workers are being trained that you know
just go with whatever the child says
never question it just affirm because
otherwise if you don't affirm you could
be leading the child into anxiety which
could lead to depression which could
lead to rejection and suicide ultimately
are we seeing a rise of that I mean
because now they also incorporate these
tell us about these puberty uh hormone
blockers
what is that and how does this also play
into this
well and you know I don't know if you'd
like to show that amaze.org video on
puberty blockers yeah we could do that I
think that would tell a lot yes
and remember these are being shown to
kids before they hit puberty so
Elementary children now this is another
video that's being shown to children
just like the other one that we showed
but this one now specifically is for
what if a child is confused then they'll
prescribe them is it necessarily what
the parents consent
puberty blockers yes
um what role does a family what role
does mom and dad play in this
well as of right now yes
County at least in the gender clinics we
have them in the children's hospitals I
know in La they do I know in Orange
County they do and
um the policy is one parent has to
consent for a minor however the
California Teachers Association just
passed a policy in January 2020 saying
that they believe that parents are
unnecessary barriers and that parent
permission or consent should not be
necessary for a child to receive puberty
blockers or hormone therapy for the sake
of equity now that's a policy that they
pass the teachers union and usually when
they pass a policy they try to move it
into legislation so I would not be
surprised at all if that starts to go
forward towards legislation
okay here we go this is the video you're
talking about
you can see it yes
hi fish come here
oh you need to
need let's see wait a second what gender
are you
a person who is transgender is someone
whose internal sense of their gender
being a boy girl or something else
doesn't match their physical body people
who feel this way sometimes feel anxious
when they begin to reach puberty and
their body starts to change in ways that
don't match their internal sense of
their gender
these feelings are totally normal
you feel you want more time to explore
how you feel about your gender before
your body starts to change
it's important to talk with a parent
counselor therapist or doctor about the
feelings you have regarding your gender
after some discussion and counseling you
may be referred to an endocrinologist
endocrinologists specialize in hormones
and they are the most likely to
prescribe puberty blockers for someone
who wants them puberty blockers are
medications that will stop your body
from changing they are usually given as
an injection or an implant they block
the production of hormones to stop or
delay the physical changes of puberty
the effects of the medication are only
temporary so if a person stops using
puberty blockers the physical changes of
puberty will Begin Again whether you
identify as male female genderqueer or
something else you're perfectly normal
and there are lots of ways to manage
puberty so that it can be a fun exciting
time rather than a scary or stressful
one
okay maybe you need more time to get to
know yourself first I'll just call you
bubbles for now uh when I see this um
Brenda I mean this is really frightening
because we know I mean one I start
thinking of this is a brilliant way for
the pharmaceutical company to make a lot
of money this is big business at the
expense of our children and and you see
how they push it as oh it's safe you
know just take a time to kind of reflect
and see do you really want to move
forward with this like you're shopping
now for a gender and and we know that
there are any any prescription any drug
that you take from Pharma I mean you got
to look at the side effects and this is
not safe there's no way this is a lie I
mean what are your thoughts please and
talk to us well puberty blockers and
then if it goes on to hormone therapy at
least to sterilization
because there are cancer risks one you
have at this time uh bone and muscle
development happening and interferes
with that uh the child's thinking
capabilities I mean you're blocking all
this
right
right they're cheap they're treating
puberty like a disease that has to be
treated there are a lot of holistic
doctors that that talk about you know
the effects and and many scientists
people if you dig a Little Deeper you
see when you interfere with the natural
process you know that God Almighty the
Creator had made the human being go
through I mean you can't expect good
things to happen
I totally agree with you
um and yet they're just passing in
California a law right now even though
there's been huge opposition to it to
tax um fund these health clinics that
are providing these um Medical
Treatments on children and adults
puberty blockers and hormone therapy
um that now it looks like they're going
to pass it to fund it
how this specific uh Dr Kelly Brogan she
and others I've read they have actually
connected many of these pharmaceutical
drugs uh you have such a growing rate of
suicide uh you have such a growing rate
of mass shootings you know and now
you're introducing more things that are
messing with the psyche of the human
being of the child I mean uh have you
looked into some of the growing numbers
of many of these things suicide and many
other mental disorders you know physical
disorders that are happening under the
pretext that no it's safe you know you
just take a time out from you know the
natural way have you gone down this and
and looked into or talked to some
medical professionals scientists who are
more broadly holistic or or
um yes I've definitely talked to Medical
Doctors I've read the uh it's called the
world professional let's see
a transgender Health
um it and it states in there that more
studies need to be done and that these
drugs are not FDA approved for this
purpose
um and yet and it's flatly stated in
these policies yet they're experimenting
on our children and
they seem to be okay with it I will tell
you I mean I'm not a psychiatrist I'm
not a psychologist I'm predominantly I'm
an educator and so my forte is the
curriculum part of it of what they're
teaching kids in schools and the
policies and laws that impact schools
and curriculum
I've seen a lot of doctors I remember
one in particular she was a lady who was
talking about
that if someone came into her office and
had a perfectly good arm leg
finger whatever the case and that this
person wanted to have it amputated that
they would
do such and such and such they would
have a protocol that they would they
would not just go ahead and amputate
them they would start to think like hold
on what's going on here with this
individual you know you got a perfectly
good arm leg but now when someone comes
in and wants to totally change you know
how the way the Creator made them now
it's actually pushed it's actually
facilitated
it's facilitated exactly it's affirmed I
can show you
um a few books for kindergarteners that
might open some eyes would you like me
to do that yes please but you get the
point the doctor was making
oh absolutely and in fact if you would
like a doctor to come in I could
definitely recommend that I know plenty
medical doctors and
um psychologists and psychiatrists that
are against this but they are having to
Buck the system
you got a lot of times toe the line how
many people are scared they're not brave
I mean may God Almighty bless you I mean
to come out like this I mean you a lot
of times you're going against many
people just follow like sheep blindly
and people are scared to uh have their
voices heard even though you have a lot
of people that disagree with this no
I believe so and I think with the
unlimited genders
um it's so out outlandish it's so beyond
common sense and ridiculous that it's
it's time for us to all stand up and
unite and say enough is enough enough is
enough
um I'll just give you an example here if
you can see this can you see this yes
okay so it says when babies are born
people ask is it a boy or a girl
foreign
s can't talk so grown-ups make a guess
by looking at their bodies
now notice it says grown-ups it doesn't
even say parents
yeah they're guessing
what they are
by looking at their bodies
some people say there are only two
genders but there are really many
genders and here's the picture I am girl
boy both neither just me
and if you see this picture you'll
notice the age of these children these
look like to me
three-year-olds four-year-olds
they're very small
and here's the definition of the gender
Spectrum
and for some people there are more than
just two choices now they're using the
word choices
there are just a few words people use
trans genderqueer non-binary gender
fluid
transgender gender neutral agender
neutral bigender third gender to Spirit
and there are even more words people are
using to describe their experience this
is called the gender Spectrum
now if that doesn't confuse a child I
don't know what does
it confuses me
now to go into this other part I want to
show is where you talk about the
targeting of the Muslim youth Muslim
children and I'm showing right now on
the screen where it says this is a
article or do teachers call the resource
for Trans Muslim youth it says I Muslim
and my gender doesn't fit me can you
talk about what this is and how is this
affecting the Educators teachers out
there
well what they're trying to
trying to tell them don't worry you can
still be a Muslim and be a different
gender you can still be a Muslim and
explore an experience experiment with
your sexual orientation you don't have
to be pigeonholed be and you need to be
yourself you need to be who you are
okay and so they're using these words
like your authentic self and the only
way you can really discover that is
through experimentation and school is
considered the safe place the safe Zone
where you will not be judged you can be
you can try different things
you know where maybe at home you
wouldn't be able to do that you would be
stifled based on your religion so
they're saying intersectionality is a
way you can still keep your religion but
it's okay to have these all these
different genders and different sex
orientations
also now what's all right as parents I
mean uh coming from you come from a
Christian background correct correct now
it's pretty clear in Christianity in
Judaism in Islam I mean here Catholics
Catholics it's all clear that God
Almighty created the first man Adam and
then you have Eve the gender is clear
the God Almighty the Creator Allah says
in the Quran the man is not like the
woman you know clearly defining the man
who he is who the woman is elevating
them both in status
etc etc uh are how do we now what is our
right to project this this belief that
we have and not compromised in it and
then uh and not fall into this because
many people are scared now many people
feel like okay can I speak about this uh
can I talk about this am I going to get
in trouble legally
yeah those are great questions Eddie
what they're really doing here and see
for me you know we live in America and
an adult can do what adult wants to do
and that's fine but when it comes to
public education public education is a
place that is supposed to respect
diversity that means that they're
supposed to respect the different
cultures and the religious variances
that are represented in their classroom
however to me this has crossed a line
into indoctrination and propaganda okay
because when I'm looking at some of
these websites I'm looking at these
books for young children I'm seeing that
They are promoting an ideology that most
people don't agree with
yet they're promoting it as fact and
Science and truth so and when black
lives matter came in with their K-12
curriculum which I sent you some of the
coloring pages
um it's also promoting this same type of
gender
um one of the coloring pages says
everybody has the right to choose their
own gender by listening to their own
heart and mind everyone gets to choose
if they are a girl or boy or both or
neither or something else and no one
else gets to choose for them so
interestingly that they are talking out
of two sides of their mouth because on
one side they say oh you're born this
way well then they keep on using the
word choose over and over again
so this isn't really making sense
um
but as far as parent rights I don't
think parents should be disrespected in
public education and I think we're
getting to a point to where we need a
huge educational reform to the place of
we need school choice
you know so that we pay we are taxpayers
and you know if if we're taxpayers and
if somebody wants to send their child to
a Muslim School a mosque school or to a
Catholic school or to a Christian
Academy you know or to a military school
they should be given that choice they
shouldn't be locked in to schools that
are absolutely
assaulting their values and their family
um
beliefs
talk to us about this father
it's the headlines read trans role
father is willing to go to jail saying I
will not allow my son to attend
relationship classes and learn he may be
in the wrong body says a Birmingham man
yes
um well they're pushing this it's not
just here but it's even more Progressive
in other countries and I'm getting
information from Australia from the UK
that this is going out globally those
amazed videos that you watched are not
just being shown in the United States
there's over 40 million views that are
international because they have put
those videos in multiple languages so
what they're doing is they're teaching
our children these things when parents
haven't even heard of it before so that
the children come home from school and
say oh well you know Mom Dad you're not
with it you don't know you don't know
what's uh like The Cutting Edge science
so kids already are you know they're
trying to individuate they're trying to
be their own people right as they're
growing up into adolescence and this
just makes the Rebellion all the worse
because now they see their parents as
backwards because the schools are
teaching something very contrary to what
maybe their religions um their imams
their priests their pastors or their
parents are teaching them it's a
contradiction
let's make this very emphatically clear
that a this is anti-science
uh B this is uh against medicine
and this is also against if you're a
God-fearing person if you love God this
is also against God the Creator I mean
this is undermining him at the same time
so all these things from scientific
perspective there's no science to back
this from a medical perspective
nothing's there am I correct when I say
this
absolutely and when it comes to parent
rights at least in California and
usually California leads the way for the
nation they are taking away our rights
one by one
um in big ways so for for one with sex
education they said no longer will it
require permission slips by parents
um and actually I worked with one of um
the imams to we tried to pass a law to
increase parent rights with many
concerned citizens in California in fact
he spoke at the hearing in um the
capital he did an amazing job
um and yet
even though we had millions of people
Catholics Christians Muslims Jews
Mormons
um many people that were opposing this
and we wanted more parent rights we were
asking for basically you know parent
permission slips if you're going to
teach this to elements
asking that they put the curriculum on
their website so that parents don't have
to take off work in order to view what's
being taught to their children
um we were asking for transparency and
openness so we didn't have to guess
what's going on when these laws are
changing and they voted no the ACLU
opposed us the American Academy of
Pediatrics opposed us
um Planned Parenthood opposed us it was
unbelievable
well they gave a they said it was based
on data and research and we read their
data and their data did not back up
their position
um it was a 30 year old study that was
actually from a drug prevention program
in Middle School
um with a sample of 200 students and at
the abstract summary at the end it said
that um you know it was good for this
case but usually when it comes to parent
permission you should go on a
case-by-case basis so
it it didn't even relate I mean our
subject was sex education for elementary
school kids it was apples and oranges
so to me they're just pushing an agenda
here to take away parent rights and to
create medical patients lifelong medical
patients with puberty blockers and
hormone therapy
let me get your reaction to one more
thing there's a big controversy
regarding a
film that seems to be
over sexualizing children and again it
goes back to our topic talking about
targeting Muslim youth because you have
an actual family that has a daughter in
there that's wearing you know you know
when we wear this uh the women wear the
hijab they're actually imitating Mary
the mother of Jesus I don't know if you
knew that
uh you know it's well I've seen it but I
did read a summary about it yeah so so
that that's that's why she's wearing the
hijab that's why any woman uh a Muslim
woman they wear the hijab because of our
deep love for Jesus peace be upon him
and his Blessed Mother Mary call her
medium so we're trying to imitate her uh
in modesty now I'm gonna go ahead and
share this have you heard of this film
called
cuties
yes it's called cuties yeah
and it's young girls before they're not
they're not even teenagers yet and they
are going against their parents because
they wanted to join a dance team whereas
a very sexualized dancing called
twerking so so how does this fit in with
what we're talking about
the way it fits in is when I read
through the international Planned
Parenthood they talk a lot about sexual
rights and that they talk a lot about
sexual pleasure and that sexual pleasure
is the right and it is the right of
actually in the sex education standards
I was shocked when I read it
um it said that it is the fundamental
sexual consent is the fundamental right
of people of all ages
so they're really stressing
um kids having sexual rights
I mean this this seems like more uh a a
growing push also for pedophilia
so this is
very scary very scary uh times we're
living in it's very large
yeah and there
okay so now with this Netflix film so
now you have these young girls you have
this Muslim girl who's growing up and
now you have these
um the other young girls they're trying
to get them to do the whole twerking
stuff and all it all it all seems like
it's under the umbrella of just fun
we're just having fun Freedom what do
you think about that all these terms
that are just nice they're nice terms
slogans that are put out there but then
the under what's the agenda underneath
right it seems it's uh this poison
yeah the agenda is is freedom at all
cost and it's leading our kids in it
into Rebellion against their parents
um rebellion and revolt against you know
probably their traditional if they're in
any type of um religious or cultural
um Family setting it's to break out and
to be your own person and to have fun no
matter what pleasure is everything and
sexual pleasure especially
there is
a big outrage also and we've had a lot
of um have you seen a lot of uh
Christian groups or uh Jewish or that
have that have spoken out against this
this film from Netflix I know there was
a petition yes
there was a a change.org um that I know
I think they got up to 170 000
um
and and I know that
um Netflix did send out a Twitter
message apologizing but they didn't
remove it from Netflix they just changed
the um poster
uh because the one that you showed was
the changed version the first one was
the girls in their um
scanty costumes in provocative oh wait
wait so the one that we just showed was
a toned down one there was one worse
than that yes yes
they portrayed these um 11 year old
girls as Las Vegas showgirls
like it's strictly like basically
strippers oh like pole dancers pole
dancers so tell me now about the and the
last thing we'll discuss here was about
the the actual toys
you sent me some stuff talk to us about
this
um and I don't know if you'd like to
maybe show this is selling at Target now
it's called poopsie and it's a unicorn
that dances and they're combining it
with a YouTube video that first of all
um they're unicorn dolls and with the
rainbow hair and then they eat slime and
then they defecate the Slime and the
Slime has different fragrances and it's
glittery so it to me what they're trying
to do with this is have a positive
association with human feces rather than
it being you know considered ooh you
know gross or Nolly it's they're having
a positive Association we've got glitter
and nice Aromas and the
I I don't know how to say this but you
know the the anus is shaped as a heart
on the doll where the Slime comes out
and I find that significant
I find it significant because in the sex
education that they're teaching there's
a stress on anal sex and it wasn't
that's different we haven't had that
before
um but this is an important point now
this is an important point that in the
sexual education at the school this
wasn't something that was stressed
before but now there's been a big change
in it yes yes and they basically when I
was reading it I was pretty shocked
because I used to work in probation and
I actually a long time ago helped write
some of the curriculum for the AIDS
prevention and when they were talking
about HIV prevention and they were
really downplaying the risks of anal sex
um I was shocked by that
um making it sound as though you know as
long as you use a condom everything's
going to be fine and not really giving
the true stats for the high risk of this
type of activity what is some of the
high risk
well first of all condoms are not even
FDA approved for anal sex
and the CDC stats show that
um 70 percent
um efficacy rate so you know that's not
that's it with perfect use of a condom
perfect 100 use
um all the time with the condom and you
know there's no such thing as perfect
use actually and it when it's not used
perfectly it goes down significantly
even planned parenthood says that
um even for vaginal sex
with unperfect use it goes down 13
percent in the efficacy rate
so if you're going from a 70 and then
you take down unperfect use that takes
it down to 57 percent efficiency
so tell us uh Brenda what can the
parents do what can the people are many
of these laws being just passed while
people are asleep at home where people
are just snoozing under the table really
quickly like how are they being passed
uh do more people mainstream media not
much coverage on this what can we do the
Main Street you keep it totally silent I
mean even the fact that we we had a our
gender definition change the legal
definition changed in 2017 in the state
of California and no not a word was said
not a word in fact even the school board
members weren't told and I contacted the
California School Board Association and
said listen you know why aren't school
board members being told this we're
passing policies with the word gender
identity and yet the implications when a
definition changed it's huge the
implications are huge because what it
means is because under the sexual
harassment and discriminatory
um
anti-non-discrimination policies I said
if a teacher doesn't go along with this
if they don't use some of these pronouns
like Z they
um
you know some of these new pronouns that
are non-binary they will be accused of
discrimination or harassment and their
jobs will be in jeopardy
their jobs will actually be in Jeopardy
that's right
so if you it's really putting
fear that they could lose their jobs
I mean explain that give us in a
scenario I mean what if you I mean if
you address someone who's out who's a
boy I mean biologically she's a female
and you address her by her biological
nature the way God Almighty created her
the way your religion defines man or
woman you can get in trouble as an
educator
you lose your job
yes
and this is actually happening have you
have any any cases that you know of
yes different yeah
and I know a teacher friend of mine she
was posting on Facebook
um she lives in the Bay Area this wasn't
even during work hours
um she posted on Facebook how she
thought these um different gender
identities were harmful to kids and she
was put on administrative leave
saying that she might be creating a
hostile environment for students if she
doesn't believe the way they want her to
believe
she did end up getting her job back but
that's how
yeah it is getting very serious
I don't know how much you know about the
statistics this is also something that's
growing it's a sad reality that you have
you have I'll give you right now
some numbers to this that the mainstream
media really doesn't cover and then when
you see films like this
uh with this cuties is new Netflix do
you see this actually contributing where
you to the human uh trafficking of young
children you have 30 million uh slaves
in the world 10 million of these are
children traffic trafficking uh in
persons in the is the trafficking in
persons is the third most profitable
business for organized crime you know
American children are the number one
victims in America you have two million
two million children are sexually
exploited in this multi-billion dollar
commercial industry
and this is huge and you don't hear much
talk about about this happening
right I think it's
it's
tribute
socializing Young children and you know
it's absolutely
they I mean they're making all kinds of
things to them masturbation at a very
young age and they're going into great
detail
um
on all the body parts which isn't
necessary and it's literally pornography
uh yeah it's it's very scary um so again
we've covered a lot there's a lot of
information I believe every parent needs
to watch this to be informed not asleep
when it comes to not naive uh and and
your closing comments what else what
what can every parent do to make a
difference
um do you want me to show one more book
yes please
from the Human Rights Campaign
called preschool
this is preschool through second grade
so these are this all the books up until
now that you showed us this is what the
teachers are using in the public schools
this is so I can't say that they're
using them I can say that they're being
promoted and encouraged to use them
um by our department of educations
um they're saying that this is inclusive
this is how to create inclusive
welcoming School climates by teaching
this
and anybody who wants more information I
give I do have a YouTube video that
actually the Muslim Community helped um
fund and so if they Google my name
Brenda lebsack they can find a lot more
videos with samples of curriculum and
videos and that yeah so this one has
um let me see
this is called he she no it's called
they she he me free to be
and this is a picture with a pronoun of
he
this is a picture with the pronoun of
she
this is a picture of the pronoun of they
meaning you can be both male and female
at the same time you could be so way way
way back up so you can be now both at
the same time also
wow
yes or you can be fluctuating gender
fluid back and forth so you can go he
one day she the next day but something
you talked about in your lecture you can
actually even if you go outside of those
pronouns if a person wants to be a cat a
dog
does that that fits into the equation
I don't know I
imagine it could be anything on the
Spectrum but I've heard this I've heard
this also yeah
this one says a pronoun called Z or tree
and what is the Z
the Z means you're non-binary that means
you're neither boy or girl and then tree
there's something else
you said tree also yeah that's right
right there tree what does a tree mean
that's a pronoun that's a pronoun
what
you can create
three pronouns it says you can change
pronouns from he to she or she to he you
can use new ones like Z or create your
own like tree
some people use they which is the
perfect way there are many many more
pronouns waiting to be discovered and
used so they're talking about like I
said the kids imagination the sky is the
limit what do you want to be it's just
like hybrid Humanity it's like Avatar
how how is the uh the the Christian
Community uh how are they I mean this is
this is a great joint effort I mean to
work together to um bring to light we
have been working together when we um
had the um Catholic Conference of
Bishops
um in the state of California we had the
Islamic Church Council for the Southern
California we had the Nazarene
denomination Assemblies of God for
Southern California
um many of large churches that came
together
um of many different you know
denominations the lutherans signed on to
and we came together to increase parent
rights just asking for permission slips
if they're going to teach these things
for elementary kids and we were denied
again we were denied by the American
Academy of Pediatrics by the ACLU and by
Planned Parenthood
how did you feel just on a side note
because sometimes Christians who also
hold many of the same values as Muslims
and we have so many things in common a
few of them is just uh the belief in one
and only one God and we believe in Jesus
I mean we believe that he was one of the
mightiest Messengers God Almighty ever
sent we believe in his Blessed Mother
there's a whole chapter named after in
the Quran we say peace
and we say peace be with you that's the
way Jesus greeted we believe in family
uh a man and woman coming together we
believe in so many things that are
similar but you have some of these uh
trepidations fear because of the
mainstream media again some Christians
have some wrong ideas about Muslims
again but when they come meet like you
did how did you feel uh when you came
into a mosque giving your lecture there
in meeting actually the community and
and to to to help Christians get because
I actually I spoke to I speak to
different Christians groups they come in
and when they come in it's a totally
different experience I had one Pastor
his name was David he said I said how
did you feel before you came to visit us
here he said I was terrified
he was that's you know when you listen
to Just the mainstream media how's Ben
how's your experience been uh with the
Muslim Community and my experience has
been wonderful full I've met so many
wonderful people
um and you know the fact is is that we
love our children and we have we have a
reason to have a righteous anger right
now an indignation and I'm telling you I
weep over this I weep over it almost
daily because I'm afraid for Humanity
I'm afraid for our children I'm afraid
for our religious freedoms of all
religions and for our rights as parents
because that's a very sacred right and
we do need to join arms and work
together
um but no I love the Muslim Community
they've been so supportive in fact they
um
they funded me they found me a
videographer
um and helped me to get the word out and
I'm so grateful to them and you know I
think sometimes we stereotype and it's
just wrong you know for people to
stereotype Christians or evangelicals as
people who blow up abortion clinics and
you know strike gay funerals that's not
the Christian Community you know and the
Catholic Community isn't a bunch of
child molesters you know and it's just
sad because a few things like that or 9
11 you know a lot of Christians think of
terrorism in 9 11 and we need to look we
need to meet each other and get rid of
these stereotypes between each other
that provide uh restrict Unity
absolutely are you also uh open if other
because I encourage more Community
leaders Imam Scholars to invite you to
their Moss so you can also give this
presentation and make the community
aware really what's going on are you
willing to come out and
oh absolutely absolutely and you know
with the covid-19 even though it seemed
to put a damper on things because I was
going into Moss I was going into
churches of many different languages
Spanish Korean
um but it doesn't have to damp in it
because actually there's webinars we
could probably meet even more people
with greater influence and we need to
not that mass media isn't going to cover
this
so we have to take it upon ourselves
to do so how can people get in contact
with you if they wanted to invite you or
see some more of your work
um they can just Brenda lebsack aol.com
or they can message me
I'm on Facebook so they can message me
you're on Facebook and those the video
that you talked about to see more of
your your videos they can go on YouTube
they just put your name Brenda yeah it's
a Google
so I tried to keep them really packed
with information because I know people
don't have a lot of time and um and by
the way you know I want to let you know
that I'm also reaching out to the gay
and lesbian Community because
um they are upset about this too they
feel like they're being misrepresented
and many of them there's a book that
just came out by an author called
Abigail Abigail schreier called
irreparable damage and it's about this
whole transgender Trend that's going on
especially with um young girls and
finding that the YouTube and um social
media is it it's becoming a contagion
um where it's just a in thing almost
like cutting or anorexia and so she's
written She interviewed a ton of parents
including many
um gay and lesbian parents that were
very upset about this gender uh craze
that's going on right now especially
unlimited genders uh one more thing I
want to ask you this is more in the
public schools is this also being a
forest or can can this be this
curriculum when it starts happening many
of these things in private schools
well as of right now it's not in the
private schools um however we need to
push back because the goal is to get
into the private schools because if they
tighten the laws where they're going
with this is that they are equal that's
why it's in the black lives matter
um curriculum because they're equating
all of these new gender identities and
sex orientation identities
um with skin color
okay so if you do not
um Embrace these ideologies you're
therefore it's implied that you're a
racist
so it's packaged in this I mean it's
very deceptive
yeah very deceptive
um and many people don't know about no
don't know about this this is this is
very important information now that
they're putting this in packaging and
it's the packaging and exactly and it's
all part of systemic racism
um it's all together
and very strategically placed
um but the sexual orientation just like
gender
how we think oh it's transgender the
sexual orientations are Way Beyond
lesbian gay or even bisexual
um it's going Way Beyond that we have
non-monogamous relationships we have
open relationships it's anything goes
there are no boundaries it's just based
on however you feel and whatever you're
attracted to
wow thank you so much thank you for the
wonderful work you're doing one more
thing have you gotten some some pushback
have there have people
um fought you against this how you are
experiencing any any pushback
well what's amazing is I have
um I've gone about this not on the
stance so much of religion as facts so
um I have been exposing and showing
facts and nobody can argue with me on
that
um and if they can't even call me a
racist because
when I went to the California Department
of Ed I advocated because they were
doing a 60-day input process but they
only provided all the information in
English and I said well what about our
immigrant population 30 percent of our
state is immigrant population you're
only allowing English speakers to even
you know agree with this information
that's never been in schools before and
so they discriminated against all of our
Spanish-speaking arabic speaking
um asian-speaking parents they didn't
have a voice at all
and I think that's racism
all right so thank you very much people
can look you up at your Facebook page
just put your name Brenda lipsack
l-e-b-s-a-c-k and then you also have
that YouTube channel that has many of
these uh more information in those
videos thank you so much uh may God
bless you for your wonderful work thank
you and I encourage I encourage
everybody who's listening many of the
community leaders to really get informed
uh to watch this again and again and
also uh invite you uh to their community
so they can get more even more informed
and ask any questions that they have
thank you so much thank you very much
Brenda and this is a great example of
someone with a lot of Courage somebody
who is helping to expose what our
children are being exposed to
an educator with over 25 years
experience she's brought many things to
light I'm sure many things that you're
having a hard time wrapping your mind
around but these are the times that
we're living in and we got to hold firm
and we have to educate our children
ourselves in our home make sure we're
living this Dean this beautiful way of
life and the creator of the heavens and
earth submission to his will not our
desires that's what Islam means that
we're doing our best to teach our
children what God Almighty the Creator
Allah what he loves and he loves when
husband and wife when a man and woman
they come together
to express themselves that feeling that
natural desire that a man has for a
woman a woman has for a man that they do
it properly a in marriage and they they
do it within the kind confounds within
the boundaries that the creator has set
and this is clear in our Deen in Islam
it is clear
and we know it's clear in Christianity
and in Judaism so people of Faith people
who believe in the creator of heavens
and earth this is a great example how we
can come together on something good to
promote that so we don't end up having
this other ideology try to snatch our
kids away from the way that has been
clear for Generations Generations since
the beginning of humanity thank you very
much again subscribe if you haven't
already support us on our patreon page
and we'll see you next time here on the
dean show peace be with you
assalamualaikum